this was already Brazil's biggest
cemetery and freshly dug graves in the
city of Sao Paulo
tell the story of a country struggling
with an outbreak which is now
accelerating staff wear protective
clothing as the funerals keep on coming
this is rapidly becoming the global
epicenter of the corona virus the
intensive care unit at this hospital is
at full capacity it only opened earlier
this month to take the pressure off
other hospitals overwhelmed by the
outbreak there is a shortage of doctors
says the local health director who then
offered this assessment this disease is
not kidding around whoever thinks it's a
joke is going to lose their life people
have to take precautions and this is the
man in charge Brazil's president Jaya
bolson ro already widely criticised for
his response to the outbreak and now in
a deepening political crisis after this
video emerged of a foul-mouthed cabinet
meeting part of an investigation into
claims he tried to meddle in police
affairs to protect family and friends I
am throwing out the water and I will
continue to throw out water from all
ministers in this regard I have the
power and I will interfere in all
ministries without exception the video
has astonished the country it's his
response to coronavirus though that seen
his poll numbers plunge while he's been
losing health ministers opposing social
distancing and supporting untested drugs
communities have taken it on themselves
to act in Rio officials are alerting the
public to the risk but it's all left a
feeling of resentment our coroner's are
not interested in the people just with
themselves and that's how we are today
unemployed people people at home
repression not far away ambulances
arrive at a field hospital in one of
Rio's more upmarket neighborhoods the
patchwork of responses across Brazil say
public health experts is nowhere near
enough the likelihood is that the
situation is much worse than
numbers suggest because Brazil has been
slow to increase testing and as some
parts of the world begin to ease their
quarantine the worst may be yet to come
in a country already in despair Greg
Milam sky names